Speaker 1: Continuing our conversation from
earlier about cults and scams. We have to
talk about Carrie Lake. Carrie Lake, who lost
her attempt at becoming governor of Arizona,
is still talking about suing to overturn the
election. At this point, I don't even know if
the people hosting her believe this drivel.
Here is Carrie Lake on with Tucker Carlson
last night. And she is still acting like
there's actually something going on here
that might allow her to become the governor of
Arizona. She won't. She won't listen to this.
Speaker 4: We vote for a full month in Arizona
with early ballots. And on Election Day,
when the Republicans showed up, the
Election Day voting was sabotaged and it.
Speaker 1: Was not sabotaged. A few tabulators
briefly didn't work. They were fixed.
Speaker 4: That's what our case
is going to prove. It's a 70 page
lawsuit that reads like a real crime novel.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, it reads like a crime
novel in the sense that it's fiction. This was
overall a bizarre interview. Here's how Tucker
Carlson introduced Carrie Lake. And this is
he devoted four and a half minutes to this,
which on the one hand isn't a lot. But for a Fox
News segment for something so absurd, they often
will do two minute interviews. And this is a four
and a half minute interview. We won't watch all of
it. Don't worry, I won't subjected to that.
Speaker 5: According to official tallies,
Kerry Lake lost her bid to become the
next Arizona governor by just over
17,000 votes. That's a great margin in a big
state. Now, Lake is suing the state's election
officials. She says many ballots were not
properly counted. She also says her opponent,
then Secretary of State Katie Hobbs, worked
illegally with big tech to silence voters online.
And for the record, that appears to be true.
Speaker 1: There is not actually evidence of that.
Speaker 5: Lake is also citing widespread printer
failures in Maricopa County. Also true, she says,
they prevented people from voting. Maricopa County
claimed they didn't stop anyone from voting,
but has not responded further. We reached out to.
Speaker 1: Kitty Hawk now understand the way they
they manipulate language. Maricopa County has
said they did not prevent anyone from voting,
but they have not responded further. It is
not on them to respond further. Lake has not
actually presented evidence of that. These
folks, I want to say they don't understand.
They certainly pretend, at least
not to understand burden of proof.
Speaker 5: About this office and got no reply
at all. Carrie Lee joins us tonight. Julie,
thanks so much for coming on.
Speaker 1: What an important
conversation we're going to have.
Speaker 5: So Maricopa County,
as far as I understand it, does not deny that a
huge number of printers didn't work on Election
Day, but they're saying it had no effect.
Speaker 1: I don't know what Carrie likes
going to say here. We're going
to check it out in a moment.
Remember, they don't deny it. The Republican
Party filed a lawsuit initially over the broken
tabulators. Once they were satisfied, a few
tabulators briefly didn't work. Everyone who
wanted to vote voted. Everything was okay.
The Republican Party retracted that lawsuit.
People are satisfied. Other than Carrie Lake.
Speaker 4: Well, it had a huge effect,
obviously. Tucker, our our voters were showing
up on Election Day. That was no secret. And the
minute the polls opened, the wheels fell off the
ballot. Printers weren't working. There wasn't
enough toner in the printers. The Tabulators
weren't working. It became a debacle and the lines
started forming right away. Some of the lines,
3 hours, 4 hours, 5 hours, and there's video
of people walking out of line. People told us and
this is in our lawsuit, that they showed up. They
couldn't even find parking because the parking
lots were full and the lines were long and many
people didn't even get to vote. And those who did
vote when they went up to get the printer out, the
printer didn't have toner in it. So the ballots
weren't dark enough and our voters were showing
up and voting 3 to 1 to for me on Election Day.
Speaker 1: Think of that. None of that is even
remotely believable, and there's no
evidence for any of it. But listen,
she's filed a lawsuit. So I guess I guess at some
point it'll all come out, right. Like Mike Pillow
used to always say, remember, Pillow.
Speaker 2: We're doing a
class action lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: And yet the information never
seems to make its way out.
Speaker 4: Both for a full
month in Arizona with early ballot.
Speaker 1: All right. And this is the
segment that you already heard Kerry Lake
then appearing on Real America's Voice,
again to give an update on this lawsuit. Now,
again, I just don't know. Does Kerry Lake
really believe this is going to go anywhere
or is it just a way to raise money? Because
if you actually look below in these tweets, she
responds, Donate to my legal fund, Save Arizona
Fund. Is this just another grift to try to make
money or does she genuinely believe this might
go anywhere? Listen to this update from her.
Speaker 4: We had three whistleblowers from
Maricopa County reach out and say the system is
flawed, seriously flawed. The three levels they
have to determine if a signature is valid or
not. They were throwing out tens of thousands
of signatures saying they were scribbles.
They in no way matched. But somewhere between
there and the ballots being completely
tossed out, they got looped back into the
system and counted as if they were fine.
Speaker 1: This is crazy. Are you
even for sometime? Between the mismatch on the
signatures she claims exists and the ballots
being tossed, they were counted as if they
were fine. So is the problem that ballots were
counted or weren't? Kerry I guess it's both.
Speaker 4: And they had no flagging done when
they laid it out. How that happened, how some were
between being flagged as a bad signature and going
into the curing process, which would mean.
Speaker 1: They were cured,
sauteed and later called smoked.
Speaker 4: Phone calls or emails to
the actual voter to see if they wanted
to come in and verify their signature.
Speaker 1: Dear God.
Speaker 4: It wasn't
happening. There was a disconnect there and.
Speaker 1: There's a disconnect. All right.
And part of the disconnect is first, the problem
was disenfranchisement. People didn't get to vote.
Now the problem is too many people voted whose
votes shouldn't actually count. Here's the real
position, right? Her supporters weren't allowed
to vote. And people who didn't really mean to vote
for Katie Hobbs had their votes counted for Katie
Hobbs. But I guess those would be her supporters,
right? I mean, it doesn't really make any
sense if her supporters weren't allowed to
vote and votes that weren't really for Katie
Hobbs were counted for Katie Hobbs. Those
wrongfully counted votes for Katie Hobbs must
have been her voters. So they were allowed to
vote. Except part of the argument is there
wasn't. If you don't know what I'm talking
about, it's because it doesn't make any sense.
Speaker 4: Three whistleblowers said that they
believed that a second level manager was pushing
these through these rejected ballots, pushing them
through as if they were approved. And we did some
calculations that we believe that up to 135,000
ballots were pushed through that should not
have been pushed through. We're asking a judge
to let us take a look at all of the. Yeah, it's.
Speaker 1: Just not going to happen. And again,
I don't know whether she believes this crap
or whether she just needs to get her followers
to believe it. None of it makes sense.
There's no evidence for all of it. It's 20,
20 all over again. Lawsuit, lawsuit,
lawsuit. They're all thrown out.
If and when something is actually granted,
they'll say, no, no, no, no. But you're just
looking at those bogus ballots and just counting
them. Again, we need to actually throw them out.
It'll be the same thing. Nothing will happen.
Kerry like lost. Katie Hobbs is going to be
the governor of Arizona. That's the bottom line.
Sorry. Two people holding out hope, if there are
actually any, that somehow Carrie Lake will end
up governor. It's as likely as that. Trump will
end up reinstated from 2020, which I guess some
people believe will happen, but it's not going to.